después de la reapertura de las
fronteras nos acercamos a ver un
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países que cree usted y bueno
efectivamente ambos que ambos candidatos
tanto petro como rodolfo hernández en
las elecciones que acaban de ocurrir
aquí en colombia habían señalado que
iban a reanudar relaciones y se han
producido ya los primeros contactos
entre el gobierno venezolano y el
presidente electo gustavo petro para que
se hagan efectivas las mismas esto va a
ser efectivamente un proceso gradual
probablemente porque recordemos que
entre colombia y venezuela se
suspendieron todo tipo de contratos en
el
pasado verdad
y son unas relaciones muy complejas y
pensemos solamente en que colombia tenía
15 consulados en venezuela venezuela
tenía siete consulados en colombia y
reconstruir todo este entramado va a ser
difícil de tomar creo que no está
efectivamente asegurado que va a haber
relaciones diplomáticas donde estoy tan
seguro es el cual va a ser el grado de
relaciones políticas
recordemos que gustavo petro a pesar de
que en el pasado fue el simpatizante
aliado del chavismo
últimamente llegó a calificar de
dictadura al rey de dictadura al régimen
de nicolás maduro